faith
this is the best for all the wrong
reasons
hi my name is charlie santori i'm the
owner of santorian sunlock and safe i'm
a safe technician meaning safe cracker
in southern california today we're going
to look at some clips on safe cracking
and films and we'll tell you whether
they're credible or whether they're
garbage
the clicking dial that hollywood loves
so much they typically have a bearing
surface on it it's usually very very
smooth if it was properly installed it
shouldn't be clicking there's like one
or two
models of a junkie
safe that you can get at staples where
the dial clicks it's not really a real
thing
[Music]
the sort of dialing sequence that she
would be doing in order to do so is not
how she's dialing here she's actually
working
backwards to to how we typically would
the principle of it is that wheels are
being searched for low spots and what
that involves is parking certain wheels
and moving other wheels and there's a
certain repetitive sequence to to doing
that by people that know how to do this
and she's not doing this here
you can do this
[Music]
there's a difference between people
burglarizing things and people
opening things the the way that we open
them to put them back in service they're
not going to be sitting around trying to
manipulate a safe open they would drill
it open even
opening a safe like this even if you're
drilling it is also extremely difficult
you're not haphazardly drilling holes in
something you're not vandalizing
something when we open safes the idea is
it's like arthroscopic surgery we're
doing it in a minimally invasive way the
whole thing is a very academic study
we're supposed to believe
when that click happened that final
click is the fence of the lock dropping
but here with vault locks and safe locks
you have to do a final turn to pull the
lock bolt back there's a certain amount
of travel that then opens that lock so
she dials the combination
here she stops at 50 the fence drops
she's saying the safe is open and he
turns the handle but the safe wouldn't
be open even if the lock was unlocked
because she didn't retract the lock bolt
you know this notion of somebody
creeping around and manipulating a safe
open it does happen and it has happened
but nine times out of ten it's
sledgehammers and wedges or grinders or
saws cutting the thing open so i want to
be generous it's three
[Music]
he's taking the fingerprint off the door
with tape could have been the cleaning
ladies print that he pulled off of there
this actually broke my head a little bit
if you pull the print off with tape and
you turn it over and put a ring on it
and put loctite in it aren't you
actually making it a cast of the inverse
of the fingerprint the safe is serious
how serious we talking scotty
it's a carbondale
carbondale's a made-up name but the
vault door itself i looked through
hundreds and hundreds of photos of
vault doors and
i'm pretty certain that the art
directors based this off of a very early
dbold
vault door
this is actually
a real tool this is a strong arm mini
rig that's
used for putting pressure when one's
drilling so
that aspect of it is definitely accurate
we'll go do a quick job it winds up
being something where you don't have
your full tool kit with you so i mean
there's lots of times when we've been
running around trying to
bend wires and make tools and sort of
have to come up with something that we
didn't have with us
supposedly he's freezing it and it's
going to expand and crack this door
apart what they showed us was the bolt
work inside of the safe and the door pan
there's a big door pan if he poured a
gallon of water in there it would spill
out the bottom of the door pan basically
if by chance he froze it and the ice
expanded i mean obviously water
can expand glaciers
expand over time the thing about a vault
door is in this case there's a thin back
panel that's like sheet metal
essentially on the back of the door so
then the idea that that's going to
expand is pure fantasy it would blow the
back panel off before it blew the door
off
there's nothing here what'd you say
it's a suit i opened up a couple of
safes that were at a blockbuster video a
while and there was astroglide condoms
and some dirty photos so i don't know if
a manager was having a fling with
somebody but that was pretty unexpected
on the more valuable side of things we
once opened a safe in an affluent part
of beverly hills that people had
recently moved into a home the former
owner was gone there were bulgari
necklaces cartier necklaces krugerrands
gia certificates i mean i i can only
imagine that it must have been a you
know mid to high six figure lick but i
think that people get traumatized when
there's that much left because they're
not expecting to have a moral conflict
sort of you know it's technically mine
but this obviously meant a great deal to
whoever it was that was living here
before it's nonsense but the mini rig is
real so i'm gonna give it a three
how would you like to make 250 grand for
one day's work
oh my god
there's certainly a lot of safes that
are
known among people who do this kind of
work that are very very difficult to
open very well well-guarded locks so
yeah there is some truth to that but of
the world's living locksmiths
do i represent your greatest chance of
opening it
i can with humility
say yes
the biggest myth i think is that there's
some boffin or there there's some maven
who has the you know
magic touch to get the thing open the
four locks
do you know what it is
no no of course not it's a rotating
randomization mechanism if you mess it
up again it locks forever you understand
forever las vegas is overrun with
zombies the idea that they're gonna
bring some genius to come and manipulate
open four locks on a vault or as is
ridiculous they would just bring a
coring crew they'd bring coring stuff
and they'd bore a hole in the side of
the vault and get it open how long
will take you to a minute
30 minutes
the idea that somebody would manipulate
open four vault locks and half an hour
is pure fantasy
he's supposedly manipulating this open
he's not even looking at the dial which
is where he would be looking for the
indications that he would use to
manipulate it open and there's also some
hieroglyphs or some scrolling that he
wrote on or he drew on the front of the
door that really has nothing to do with
what he would be doing in order to get
this open
[Music]
the doors are always heavy you're
talking about a multi-multi-ton door
there are compression systems that that
have spinning wheels not all vault doors
have those some have handles
[Music]
according to him this vault has four
locks on it when the vault door swings
open we see that there's actually only
two vault locks on the back of the door
and a time lock with five movements i've
never seen a five movement time lock i'm
gonna give it a two as far as the
realism goes
[Music]
he's using an auto dialer there are such
tools i mean they don't look like a
vacuum cleaner hooked up to a xerox
machine it's smaller it's portable you
hook it up and
it it runs through it parks wheels and
it runs through a dialing sequence the
advantage is on some safes that have
glass re-lockers in them or that might
be problematic to drill or some people
don't have the necessary tools to open
some of those safes
[Music]
he's reading the paper at one point and
he's sitting around and that's i mean
that's pretty accurate it's not an
instantaneous process the much earlier
version sometimes could take anywhere
from like i think 10 to 30 hours to open
a safe the newer ones um are faster and
if one of the numbers is known then it's
even infinitely faster a lot of times
people set them up in their shop and
they go off for the day and they come
back the following day we don't use an
auto dialer people who are able to
manipulate well can usually open
something in you know 30 minutes 45
minutes
[Music]
the weird and wonderful thing now is a
tape measure a tape measure is very very
useful you know they're telling kids
that they don't have to learn math and
that there's no right answers to math
you can't do this job without being able
to read a tape measure that's for sure
but no as far as high-tech tools go
there's
lots of different picks for certain key
locks
people have to think of their safes and
their vault doors as the last line of
defense you should have alarms you
should have cameras make sure there's no
outlets around in close proximity if
it's a smaller safe if you can stick it
in a horrible position where it's hard
to get to sometimes under cabinetry
under furniture and truthfully the best
safe is one that no one knows is even
there so that's why in floor safes are
very popular wall safe someone can just
cut it out of the studs if they know
that it's there about a four or five
because there are auto dialers
[Music]
the one element of this that is correct
is that often times when there's a vault
lock out a lot of vaults can be opened
from the inside there's a way to open
the door
sometimes but there's not another lock
on the inside that somebody would have
to crack
hey
hey that's my hearing aid as far as a
listening device goes people do use amps
usually has a little magnet on it
so it sticks or if it's a stainless
thing that it won't stick to you can
hold it there tape it in place and it's
got a little pot on it that the level
turns up and when you're dealing with a
metal door the um sound actually travels
very very well just to be generous we'll
say three
the main issue
is if he was using a cutting torch to
cut that square the gear that's right in
back of there that supposedly he's
moving would probably have been damaged
as well as any sort of electrical
components there's lots of metal that
comes off as far as burglary goes people
use torches often and even earlier on
safe technicians used to use
torches and and lances because there's
certain metals that are very very hard
to drill
typically vault locks are a little
bigger safe locks are a little smaller
but
they all work on the the same principle
that there's a blocking point and so
that aspect of it that that something
small is actually keeping something
large locked that aspect of it is very
true a lot of vault doors use
yolks there's pivoting there's pivoting
yokes but it's still a lock bolt
attached to a lock i would say like like
a like a 3.5 i will say that there are
certain locks that do have a stepper
motor in them that to open them
sometimes when they're being drilled
there's a a gear that gets turned a
certain way
the only real issue that i probably have
is they're using pneumatic drills i you
know i doubt somebody would use
pneumatic lines
this comes closest to what we do
on a regular basis
they've drilled into the safe before
they hit glass
normally the glass would be much much
closer to the back of the door so you
wouldn't have this much working space in
there there's two two and a half three
inches of working space
you see them stick a boroscope up they
find the cable loop she sticks a wire in
she lassos the cable the only real
issue is that they're going to tie this
off to a chair with people sitting on it
that's that's nonsense that's not
necessary all they'd have to do is take
vice grips probably and clamp them right
at the door and that cable's not isn't
isn't going anywhere it's a
spring-loaded thing we have to assume
that she had intimate knowledge of what
kind of safe it was somebody leaked the
information to her nine times out of ten
somebody knows that there was a safe
somewhere and it's not necessarily the
person who knew that it was there but a
lot of times they sell the information
to somebody else they pass it on to
somebody else like paul rudd coming into
your
house with uh an air mattress and freon
and a jug of water to blow your vault
door off it's like probably like a nine
or a 9.5 as far as that goes it's one of
the best that we've seen so far
this is the
heist that happened at
88.90 hatton garden where a bunch of
geriatric ex-gangsters cored the vault
and they breached it and they cleaned
out i think 70 plus boxes when this
story broke i was obsessed with it
i think they're even using the exact
gear that was actually used to
get into the vault my understanding is
is it happened over a three-day weekend
they wound up using a coring rig
um they cored overlapping holes when
they realized that they had to get a
pneumatic pump they had to they built a
brace and they put a pneumatic pump in
in order to force the boxes away from
the wall
the boxes obviously inside of this vault
are not the same boxes that were inside
of the actual hat and garden vault
because the photos that we've seen was a
hodgepodge of different kind of locks
and boxes different size boxes in this
one they're much more uniform this
really i mean is like probably like a
9.5 or a 10 out of 10 really
this is the best for all the wrong
reasons
dmx rest in peace but
all
all i'll say is that if dmx shows up at
your house with a bazooka to open your
vault your problem's getting out of hand
so entertainingly stupid we have to look
at this we're on the fourth floor of a
bank building they're shooting a bazooka
through a wall i mean it's we're gonna
give it a three not based on anything
technical at all
the tool that james khan is using is is
real the drill bit that james conn is
using
in there is is is about this big okay
and the the kind of bit that we
typically use to drill open a safe
if we're scoping something is about this
big
but if you look at the proximity of of
how the wheels sit to where that dial is
and the way the light is shining on the
wheels my sense is that this is a little
bit of a mock-up there are many many
safes older safes that that utilize a
punching technique like that in this
situation i don't believe that that's
what would have been
necessary i mean especially with the
hole that big the gates could have been
dialed up but again i think that we're
coming up against trying to have
authentic realism and trying to maintain
a certain amount of secrecy
and trying to give the audience a little
taste of what's actually real i would
have to give this like a like a 8.5
probably you know in a
slow year we opened probably three 300
plus shapes on a busy year probably
closer to five i get to maybe exercise
that part of my shadow and i get to help
people in the process so i mean i i
can't think of a thing i'd rather do
thank you very much for watching if you
liked what you saw
click on the link above